retour à l'insouciance pour de nombreux
israéliens manger à la terrasse d'un
restaurant
un plaisir qui se faisait attendre pour
shimon et sa femme venue profiter de
cette réouverture avec des amis les
entreprises de la restauration ont connu
une crise année dernière et je pense que
c'est bien de venir et de faire preuve
de solidarité maintenant qu'on est
autorisé à sortir de chez nous et qu'on
a plus de liberté
c'est important de venir soutenir les
restaurants et d'espérer que les choses
vont se poursuivre dans ce sens là de
manière à ce qu'il y ait une continuité
pour les commerces
c'est très important avec 40% de la
population vaccinée l'état hébreu
revient progressivement à la normale
après un troisième confinement mi
février
mais pas pour tout le monde car il faut
être détenteur du fameux passeport vert
octroyé à pour avoir reçu ces deux doses
de vaccin ou être guéri ducobu de 19
pour les restaurateurs peu importe
l'important n'est pas là lorsque le
restaurant est fermé
les dettes s'accumulent qu'il s'agisse
du loyer des taxes municipales de nos
dépenses quotidiennes aujourd'hui nous
avons ouvert après un an d'inactivité de
chômage nous avons mis nos employés en
congé sans solde puis on les a rappelés
puis on les a remis et aujourd'hui on
les rappelle à nouveau notre principale
préoccupation est sans faire de
politique de savoir s'il y aura un
quatrième et un cinquième confinement
dont il nous sera très très difficile de
nous relever les écoles et les collèges
sont également autorisés à rouvrir dans
les zones les moins touchées du pays
l'aéroport ben gourion de tel aviv
accueillera lui désormais 1000 voyageurs
quotidiens contre 200 il ya quelques
jours
côté contamination les chiffres sont à
la baisse elles étaient au nombre de
trois mille six cents par jour il ya une
semaine contre 10000 à la mi janvier des
chiffres encourageants mais les
responsables de la santé publique
entendent rester prudent si nous
n'agissons pas de façon responsable si
nous ne suivons pas les directives la
possibilité d'un quatrième confinement
avant les élections est réelle mais pour
l'air benyamin nétanyahou a d'autres
priorités
il compte bien récolter les lauriers de
sa campagne de vaccination massive
yves lors des élections législatives du
23 mars les quatrièmes en moins de deux
ans et selon les sondages son parti le
likoud pourrait une fois de plus
remporté la mise même s'il ne semble pas
en mesure de gouverner seul